what's up everybody we are in desperate  need of a pipeline of employees that are  willing to go to the garyvee school of  career here's the thing though we have  pay do jobs at vaynerland garyland we  need people who like love that like full  day of the mundane like we need people  who literally are in the business of  actually communicating with real human  beings business leads as team Gary  members to get them out to be friends  swag to get them to connect with us on  LinkedIn to like do the day-to-day  trenches work but you're like a rookie  on the team and you know that's going to  give you leverage to eventually put the  C on your jersey as the captain there's  this garyvee school that feels foreign  in 2023. you're like me like a robot  like you're doing it there's a major  group of people that see that as their  opportunity to get close to the Sun and  go there and we're looking for you if  you're that person fill out the Google  form and join our team